les vingt-sept ne parviennent pas à
accorder leurs violons
une coordination difficile à l'heure où
les autorités italiennes ont pris tout
le monde à contre-pied avec une annonce
ce samedi leurs frontières seront
ouvertes à partir du 3 juin la
possibilité à partir du 3 juin prochain
il sera possible de voyager à
l'intérieur des pays de l'union
européenne son obligation de quarantaine
pour ceux qui arrivent en italie
cela favorisera la création des
conditions d'une reprise du tourisme est
la quarantaine lever une mesure forte
dans un pays où le tourisme est un
secteur clé de l'économie autres pays
européens très touché et l'espagne
adopte une stratégie différente les
étrangers arrivant dans la péninsule
ibérique seront contraints à partir du
22 mai à une mise à l'isolément de 14
jours
une décision que regrette la france qui
a imposé aux espagnols la même mesure
par réciprocité
le ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner appel à plus de coordination à
l'échelle du continent
je pense que il est essentiel que nous
question inverse des décisions courant a
ordonné au niveau européen surtout sur
l'air à shenzhen et ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui et la décision unilatérale
de l'espagne cette semaine de litanies
annoncé ce matin ne conforte pas ce que
nous devons faire travailler ensemble en
solidarité donc j'aurai l'occasion
d'échanger avec nos homologues dans le
week-end pour que nous puissions adapter
nos règles si certains pays on sorte que
la protection de l'espace européen
notamment des avis de pays où le virus
est encore très actif il même au sein de
l'europe vis-à-vis de territoire sur
lequel le virus sera encore que à clips
seront amenés à proposer aux prémices de
prendre des décisions qui protège les
français
symboliquement réuni à schengen au
luxembourg les chefs des diplomaties
allemandes et luxembourgeoises espèrent
de leur côté une réouverture progressive
des frontières européennes
à condition que les données sanitaires
le permettent europa league
l'europe est fondée sur le fait qu'il
est sans frontières et je crois que les
citoyens mais comprendrait plus très
longtemps une europe ayant des
frontières
c'est pourquoi nous avons une grande
responsabilité dans la lutte contre la
pandémie pire ici un sillon à réussir en
éliminant progressivement la foncière
comme orgie en place sera à nouveau une
europe sans frontières et c'est ce que
les citoyens attendent
la commission européenne souhaite une
réouverture concertée si des décisions
plus précises sont attendus d'ici à la
mi juin elle les états de l'ue avance
pour le moment en ordre dispersé